here it all starts in a few hours so
it's a drive-through clinic that's
providing flu shots
in the comfort of your own car and out
here this is where it starts at 11
o'clock this morning
this is dignity health's saint martin
campus located by warm springs and
cimarron
down here in the southwest valley and
doctors are warning that this could be a
dangerous flu season with the
coronavirus pandemic
they say getting both at the same time
could be devastating for a person's
health
doctors also say the best way to prevent
the flu is by getting an annual flu shot
it's recommended for everyone six months
of age and older especially people 65
and up
pregnant women and those with certain
medical conditions last month governor
steve sisilak urged people
to do their part we do not want to see a
huge
surge in flu cases on top of covet 19
cases
overcrowding our hospitals and
preventing nevadans
from getting the care we need
today's drive-through flu shot clinic is
from 11am to 2pm the website to
pre-register is easy to remember
immunize nevada.org we checked this
morning and they still had a few spots
available
and also they asked to bring your
insurance card getting a flu shot should
be
free under most plans and also when you
drive up to wear your face mask even if
you are inside
your own car reporting live this morning
from the southwest hector mejia
8 news now